this ain't high school man
get a new level here have not earned
teammate status yet who the hell are you
Oh Jake Bradford until you do your
nobody like to introduce you the new
guys to rules no booze in this house
number two no girls upstairs in those
bedrooms I'm seriously worried about
these new guys we have a little
tradition welcome in the new guys look
at what we have here a ladies party
later tonight the baseball houses you
should be investing this energy
elsewhere what husbands I like the quiet
guy in the backseat there's nothing new
yeah I can see how that could get
threatening any guy coming in getting
all the ladies how's a joke okay joke
right here
did he just call it a joke as when he
implied
how did you know what room I was in I'm
an investigative journalism major so yes
I know my name then yes as soon as you
tell me starting to have an identity
crisis we've danced at a disco dance the
cotton eyed Joe and kicker attire and
here we are punks for a night we have to
embrace your inner strange man please be
weird
it's about finding out who you are you
got to hand man do you guys want to try
a little telepathic stuff do it [ __ ]
what am I thinking about baseball having
a tail cereal to see my sharks stars
have tails good point it's a good push I
had to tell ya I'm pretty sure that that
is a new school record